Orphan elephants need a lot of affection.
Every day, the carers at the IFAW Wildlife
Rescue Center spend several hours playing
and cuddling with them.
Experience has shown that otherwise, they
waste away.
The center is also home to 13 baby rhinos,
some Indian hog deer, leopards and various
types of ape.
Most of them come from the nearby Kaziranga
National Park.
This baby elephant was rescued from a ditch
it had got stuck in.
That sort of thing happens often.
Traffic accidents are also common.
Baby elephants don't have very robust immune
systems.
We need to be very careful with them.
We used to make sure there was always a carer
with them, but it's too risky.
They get their trunks into everything and
they can easily pick up infections from humans.
Dr. Basumatary is keen to limit
contact between the baby elephants and their
carers - without depriving the calves of the
bodily warmth they need to survive.
These two baby elephants are now sharing their
quarters.
There's a yard they can play in, and a roofed
hut where they can sleep.
At night, when temperatures drop, they even
wear pajamas and slippers.
We do our best to look after the calves in
a species-appropriate way.
They're kept outside to recreate forest life
with their mothers.
It also helps them adjust when they're released.
In Assam, animals and humans live in close
proximity.
The road connecting the Kaziranga National
Park with the veterinary clinic is one of
the busiest in the region.
The state's main industries are tourism and
agriculture.
Working elephants are a common sight.
Tea plantations line the hill slopes.
Assam tea is world famous.
On the other side of the road are rice plantations.
Assam is flood-prone, so harvests are often
ruined.
The floods come twice a year.
The Gogoi family are making rice flour.
A few repairs are needed on the house.
In autumn, a herd of deer escaping the rising
flood water sought refuge on their land.
Down there is our village, Mohpora.
Less than a kilometre in that direction is
the national park.
It's home to wild animals.
Rhinos, elephants, tigers, water buffalo and
many others.
If the river bursts its banks it puts their
lives in danger.
And then they come to the village.
Two thirds of his last harvest was ruined.
He had to resort to planting mustard seeds,
which grow fast, to make sure he had at least
some income.
Our problems are mounting.
The tea plantations are expanding across the
slopes, reducing the forest - the elephants'
habitat.
So they come down here and ruin our crops.
They destroy our homes and kill people.
The water buffalo also leave the park in search
of food.
The tigers prey on their calves, and go crazy.
And kill more people.
Tiger attacks ocurr every month.
Phulmai Choudhury's father-in-law suffered
one on his way to work one morning.
Her husband can't bear to talk about it.
My father in law was badly wounded.
A woman from the village found him.
He was carried back home on a blanket.
We took him to hospital but he'd already lost
so much blood, and died the same day.
Children aren't allowed to play outside in
the mornings and evenings, when the danger's
most acute.
In the National park the animals are allowed
to roam free.
Its rhinoceros population is one of the most
stable in the world.
But to locals, it feels like the government
cares more about wildlife than it does about
humans.
That's why they're taking matters into their
own hands.
Every night, local men patrol the border to
the national park.
They use torches to scare off any roving animals.
Torches wouldn't be much use if the animals
turned aggressive.
But their families in the village feel safer.
The
elephants have to get used to living in the
wild.
The baby elephants born in the national park
have grown into a herd.
They're taken out every day to learn how to
look for food - and also to avoid villages
and roads.
Next year, they'll be moved to another national
park where they'll roam free.
We raise them, feeding them with bottles.
It's always very sad when we have to take
them to the Madras Park.
Sometimes I go there and call them - and they
come and see me.
It's good to see them in their habitat.
In the wild, where they belong.
But that's still a long way off.
For the time being, the herd still has a lot
to learn.